[Música]
echa un vistazo por la ventana ponte tus
gafas y las usas Tal vez quieras
utilizar binoculares o una lupa ahora
qué ves Bueno sea lo que sea no son las
múltiples capas de vidrio delante de ti
pero te has preguntado cómo algo tan
sólido puede ser tan invisible para
entenderlo tenemos que entender lo que
es el vidrio Y de dónde viene todo
comienza en la corteza terrestre donde
están dos de los elementos más comunes
silicio y oxígeno estos reaccionan
juntos para formar dióxido de silicio
cuyas moléculas se arreglan en una forma
cristalina regular llamada cuarzo
el cuarzo se encuentra en la arena donde
se conforma la mayoría de los granos y
es el ingrediente principal de muchos
tipos de vidrio
habrás notado que ese vaso no está hecho
de múltiples Trozos de cuarzo
los bordes de los granos rígidos y los
pequeños defectos en la estructura del
cristal reflejan y dispersan la luz
pero cuando el cuarzo se calienta lo
suficiente la energía adicional hace que
las moléculas vibren hasta que se rompan
Los lazos que las unen y se convierten
en líquido al igual que el hielo se
derrite y forma agua a diferencia del
agua el dióxido de silicio líquido no
retorna a un cristal sólido al enfriarse
en cambio conforme las moléculas pierden
energía son menos capaces de moverse a
una posición ordenada y el resultado es
lo que se llama un sólido amorfo un
material sólido con la estructura
caótica de un líquido que permite que
las moléculas llenen los vacíos
libremente Esto hace uniforme la
superficie del Vidrio a nivel
microscópico y permite que la luz lo
golpee sin ser dispersada
Pero esto no explica por qué la luz
puede atravesar el cristal en lugar de
ser absorbida como con la mayoría de los
sólidos por eso debemos ir hasta el
nivel subatómico quizás sepas que un
átomo consiste en un núcleo con
electrones orbitando alrededor de él
pero en su mayor parte es espacio vacío
De hecho si un átomo fuera del tamaño de
un estadio el núcleo sería como un
guisante en el centro mientras que los
electrones Serían como granos de arena
en los asientos exteriores esto deja
mucho espacio para que la luz atraviese
sin golpear a estas partículas entonces
la pregunta no es porque el cristal es
transparente sino porque todos los
materiales no lo son la respuesta tiene
que ver con los diferentes niveles de
energía que pueden tener los electrones
en un átomo es como las diferentes filas
de asientos en las gradas del estadio un
electrón es asignado a sentarse en una
fila pero podría saltar a otra mejor si
solo tuviera la energía
absorber uno de esos fotones de luz que
pasan a través del átomo puede darles la
energía que el electrón necesita pero la
energía del fotón tiene que ser la
cantidad correcta para llevar un
electrón a la fila siguiente
si no solo dejará pasar al fotón y es lo
que pasa con el vidrio las filas están
tan separadas que un fotón de luz
visible no puede proporcionar suficiente
energía para que un electrón salte entre
ellas los fotones de luz ultravioleta
por otro lado dan la cantidad justa de
energía y son absorbidos por ello no
puedes broncearte a través del Vidrio
ser Sólido y transparente le ha dado al
cristal muchos usos a lo largo del
tiempo
desde ventanas que dejan pasar la luz y
mantienen afuera a los elementos a
lentes que nos permiten ver tanto los
vastos mundos Más allá de nuestro
planeta como las pequeñas cosas que nos
rodean es difícil imaginar la
civilización moderna sin cristal y sin
embargo rara vez pensamos en su impacto
es precisamente porque sus más
importantes y útiles cualidades son no
tener rasgos distintivos Y ser invisible
por lo que a menudo nos olvidamos de que
existe ahora conoce más sobre el vidrio
a continuación Qué hace que el Ketchup
sea tan difícil de servir examine la
física de los líquidos con este video
[Música]